[Music]
Nvidia just released the RTX 4060 which
I have over here oh and this is one of
the most affordable gpus you can buy
right now but there is a big butt as a
Creator is this gonna be good for you or
not because we had some bad news with
the 46 TI and I have some mixed news
with the 4060. there are some good signs
still though but how does it compare to
the likes of
3060 from previous generation is the
4060 actually better it's gone smaller
as you can see let's take a look at the
performance and the sponsor of the video
[Music]
looking for a cheap way to license your
windows check out who Keys through the
links in the video description make sure
to use the code tn20 to get a 30 off
paste the license to the activation
settings and you're all done this
license is for Windows 10 but you can
upgrade it to Windows 11 for free they
also offer Microsoft Office 19 license
use the same code tn20 to get a 30 off
check out who keys.com in the video
description below because this is like
the budget end of the card and the MSRP
for this is a 299 in the US or 279
pounds here in the UK but the thing is
actually when you buy this zoltec
version you get this Spider-Man version
which is actually the MSRP version you
get just some goodies and stickers and
stuff inside you don't get a bag this
time but you get a little character and
things if you're interested you might
like it it's also the OC Edition but I
think most of the cars out there are
going to be OC editions so then the GPU
is actually called ad-107 not 106 as we
have on the 4060 TI it's the same
process node and the Cuda cores have
been shaved down quite a bit from the
4060 TI this is 3072 Cuda cars if you
look at the 2060 super it's a even less
at 2176 but the 3060 from previous
generation has actually more killed a
Cars 3
584. the tmus are also less than the
3060. they tend to cause though we have
more than the 3060 double the amount the
RT cores we also have more on the 3060.
the memory type of is gddr6 and we have
8 gigabytes of vram which is the same as
the 4060 TI but the 3060 has 12
gigabytes of the same memory and when we
look at the memory bus then we again see
a little bit of an issue there this is
only a 128-bit bus which is the same as
on the 4060 TI the 2060 super and
comparison is 256 which is double that
and the 30 60
192. the memory bandwidth as you can see
is the lowest in the bunch here as well
and we'll see how that reflection
benchmarks later on the bus interface is
PCA
gen4x8 slot which is actually kind of
bad news for those who are running maybe
very old 1060s and you want to upgrade
that means that if you don't want to
upgrade any of your other parts of the
PC system and perhaps you're running
something from 10th gen Intel or even
earlier and if your motherboard doesn't
support or the CPU doesn't support PCI
Gen 4 this card sorry this card is
actually going to run at X8 PCA gen 3
bandwidth just so you know the TDP is
115 watts and if I used the MSI
afterburner we can shift it a little bit
and get 130 Watts pulled from there get
a little bit more the card is going to
perform absolutely fine you get extra 13
you know power through it good you get a
little bit more performance if you want
to do that but that's about that and the
msrb is 299 dollars so if you're looking
at the market right now where does this
one slot in there you can get a 30 60
for 279 or 270 even some of these I can
see on Amazon in there if you're going
to look on eBay or somewhere like
secondhand Market you can get those
cards even cheaper so the 3060 is
actually cheaper right now than the 4060
which it should be right the previous
generation should be cheaper but what
about performance then let's have a look
at those benchmarks if you want to check
out my test Ben shut up and how I'm
testing this then check out I'm going to
leave the test bench each item in the
description below and bear in mind these
are Creator benchmarks if you're not
familiar with this channel already first
of all looking at geekbench 5 something
that the GPU does generally lots of
different things like shaders and
calculating light and all sorts of
rendering different parts of What GPU
does it's very synthetic but you might
see bits of each of these little tests
that this test does in other programs
but here we can really see easily where
does the GPU line up and how much better
obvious is it from previous generation
so the 4060 TI is actually quite a bit
better 22 in
opencl35 in Cuda and 21 in Vulcan and if
you look at the 2060 super you can see
we're about 10 to 16 faster but the 3060
from previous generation is only five to
six percent slower in the opencl and
Cuda scores and Vulcan scar is pretty
much exactly the same as previous
generation so then photoshop application
now this is an older version of
Photoshop that I'm using and I know the
newer version of Photoshop does utilize
some more GPU aspects and some of the AI
features you can use a GPU acceleration
in there and it's good to see that even
photo editing applications start to
utilize GPU more which just makes the PC
even faster but generally still the
difference between the worst GPU and RTX
1490 for example isn't that big so here
we can see that the 4060 TI is five
percent faster and looks like everything
kind of makes sense right in the new
generation but then the 2060 super is
eight percent faster than the 4060 TI
and we started to scratch the head and
wonder what is going on the GPU score on
the 2060 super is
28.8 percent faster which is ridiculous
now the 3060 is 31 faster in the GPU
scores and about 10 percent faster in
the overall score for Photoshop so the
3060 is faster than the 4060
let's keep going moving on to video
editing and Premiere Pro the rtx4060 ti
is about three to six percent faster
than the 4060 and in GPU score about 10
faster so there's quite a you know jump
between the two
um tiers here 46 TI and 4060. but the
2060 super is actually two to four
percent faster than the 4060 so a card
from two generations ago is still
beating this 4060 in Premiere Pro in
every single aspect as you can see GPU
score about 8.6 faster extended Xbox go
faster everything is faster standard
standard live playback is faster even
though we've got a two generations New
Media engines in there and all their
encoders but still and if you're looking
at the 3060 which interestingly performs
a little bit slower than the RTX 2060
super is about 1.4 percent faster in the
extended overall score but about seven
percent slower in the standard overall
score also the live playback is a slower
on the 30 60 probably because of the
higher clock speeds on the 4060 just
because the card clock speeds also
affects the media engine inside when the
card is running faster for example
running faster clock speeds the media
engine runs faster as well which means
that it plays back or can encode or
decode video better as well and that's
what we can see compared to the 3060
because the clock speeds have improved
on the 4060 but the GPU score is 15
faster on the previous generation so uh
yikes that's not quite good news and if
you look at the extended export score as
well where we actually can use the
encoders and the clock speed should make
the encoder call faster it's 14 faster
on the 3060. so yeah again the 4060
doesn't look that impressive on Premiere
Pro bear in mind the previous 3060 had
12 gigabytes of vram and the memory
bandwidth was better the boss was better
than this 4060. go going to After
Effects we can see that the 4060 TI is
about three percent faster in the
overall score and the GPU score is about
two percent faster than the 4060 here
the 2060 super is faster than both of
them so wait a second a card from two
generations ago is faster than the 4060
and the 4060 TI interesting the 3060 is
even faster than all of these as you can
see the 3060 is the fastest in this
Bunch the GPU score is 11 faster than
the 4060 and overall score is four
percent faster uh sorry what is going on
here are we going forwards or backwards
here moving on to DaVinci Resolve and
here I've got to make a very big knot
the 3060 Benchmark for resolve is
actually DaVinci Resolve 17.4.5 which
you can't actually compare 17 DaVinci
Resolve 17 and DaVinci Resolve 18
benchmarks because there is a big
difference for example the 2060 Subaru
if I compared it between exactly the
same system but separate versions of the
software DaVinci Resolve 17 and 18 then
I got about 10 difference in there when
we're looking at the 1490 for example
then the difference was about 17 okay so
in the higher end scale about 17 and
lower end of the scale about 10 so right
now there what I'm showing you is the
previous version if we calculate about
10 percent better then you can see that
those scores look absolutely ridiculous
as you can see the 3060 is about four
percent slower than the 4016 and because
I don't have the 3060 in here anymore
then um I'm afraid I can't show you this
and you might be saying what the heck is
this card then well this is actually 30
70 but because the 30 70 from saltac and
3060 are exactly the same I can show you
this card and you know you don't even
know this is 30 70. the extent that is
standard overall score would be faster
than again the 40 60. uh embarrassingly
the 8K media score will be be about
twenty percent faster fusion score maybe
about three percent slower and GPU
affects about 15 slower which just shows
again that the RDX 3060 is a better
option for DaVinci Resolve especially
when you get 12 gigabytes of vram so now
that's about it for the bad news the
good news are going to go in a moment
but why is this so bad then and I think
it's due to the bus the memory bus
because that is 128 bit the 2060 super
is 256 and the 3060 is 192 and as you
can see that makes a huge difference in
the creative applications here where we
utilize the vram and the memory of the
card is just the bottleneck is the boss
there in a moment you're going to see 3D
benchmarks and you can see that when we
take the memory bus kind of out of the
equation and just see how fast is the
card and calculating and rendering some
of the 3D scenes where we don't have to
utilize a lot of the vram and just
looking at the pure rendering
performance of the card then you can see
that the new generation tends to cause
and tmus and Cuda cores they actually
make a big difference but in an
application where we have video editing
or photo editing or after effects or
something where it's mixed even in 3D
when it's mixed when you load some of
your assets on the vram now we have less
as well it's not going to be as good
because the lower memory bus so in V Ray
the 4060 TI is about 10 faster in the
Cuda and about three percent faster in
the RTX cars the 2060 super as you can
see is about 50 to 56 percent slower
than the 4060 which is a big gain and
the 3060 again here is 29 to 233 percent
slower in the Kuda and RTX core so you
can see that the 4060 is actually better
in the actual you know rendering
performance of 3D in blender we can see
the same kind of results here the 3060
is up to 32 percent slower than and the
4060 the 460 TI is about 16 to 24 faster
and 2060 super is quite a bit slower
there as well roughly about the same as
the 3060 but still quite a bit slower in
octane bench I don't have the 3060 in
here anymore so unfortunately I don't
have the results here but you can see
that the 2060 super is 32 slower and
perhaps the 3060 would have been formed
roughly around the same the 460 TI is
only 14 faster here actually if we look
at the conclusion of 3D rendering actual
3D capability of this card then it is
quite good you can see that if we purely
render some stuff on it samples per
mirror in blender or v-ray it is good
but the vram becomes an issue here now
the power draw the card pulls only 115
Watts which is actually good news and
this is some of the good news of this
card is that we've moved forward and
cards have become very very efficient so
you can see compared to the 30 60 100
170 Watts it's pretty pretty crazy how
much more efficient this 4060 is and
that's why this card can be so small and
be completely fine even with 113 percent
uh power limit it's going to be
completely completely fine I think
there's only one heat pipe in here as
well so in terms of temperatures you
don't need to worry about this card and
if you do want to build something very
very small this card will fit into most
of these builds because it is truly very
very small in every single aspect now in
terms of the power connector we only use
in one eight pin a PC power connector so
no fancy power connectors you can just
plug in one there could have been six
pin as well but eight pin I guess is
better right now some of the other good
sides about this card what else do you
get with the 4060s and you don't get
with a 30 60 is av1 encoding now this
card doesn't have like all of the other
Nvidia 40 series cards don't have dual
encoders only the 4070 TI and above have
have a dual encoders by the way can I
just make a mention here where I do
think that the 4070 TI should have been
a 4080 or it's a cut down 4080 like
Nvidia said in the first place because
if you look at laptop gpus laptop gpus
only 40 80 and above have dual encoders
but on desktop suddenly the 4070 TI is
the one that has dual encoders and
anything above has dual encoders this
one here is single encoder but you do
get the av1 encoding support which means
that if you want to stream to a
streaming platform or stream video av1
streaming is so much more efficient and
have a look at my secrets for the Nvidia
40 series cards where I go a little bit
more into it and I'll show you why av1
is so much better in terms of quality
and bandwidth and all of the benefits of
av1 highly recommend you check that one
out so then for creators is it worth it
or not and honestly I've come to the
same conclusion what is NVIDIA doing the
lower you go with the 40 series cards
the worse the performance is compared to
the previous generation the higher end
cards absolutely blow everything out of
the water compared to the previous
generation the 1490s like I know this
sounds ridiculous but for creators this
is like the best bang for buck it is
just so good performance when you start
going down the price in the town down of
the tears they start to become worse and
worse and worse and worse of a deal now
this one here I would actually probably
if you don't need av1 I would probably
go with a 3060 just because you get 12
gigabytes of vram which a lot of the
applications now is much more beneficial
it's a shame that this is eight
gigabytes of vram it could have been 12
because then whoa we might have had a
little bit of a different story there
but right now looking at photo video
editing applications I can't really
recommend it I'm sorry I really would
like to but I can't and the same with 3D
I would like to recommend it and even
though this potentially has good power
follow there and you can use this but
again if you're actually using it in an
application and start to fill the vram
their memory buses start to become an
issue and again it's not going to be
better than the 3060 for example now for
creators I'm really struggling to make
sense of this card for gamers perhaps
that could be a different story so go
have a look at some of the gaming
reviews but right now not really unless
this card is much cheaper than what we
get with the 3060 because right now you
can get the 30 60 for the same price or
even cheaper than this one that performs
better so I don't know but if you want
to build yourself the best bang for buck
create a PC and you thinking look I'm
sick of spending money on stuff that
actually doesn't give me performance
then I highly recommend you check out
the best bank robot created PC build
guide in the description below there's
four parts and I'm gonna explain
everything you need in those there pick
the one that's closest to your budget
and then you'll see upgrades downgrades
and remember guys if you like the video
hit that like button bye
[Music]